And now it's to you, Scoutmaster.
The time is marked by a lack of truth.
The world turns to Mason. Scoutmaster.
Scoutmaster will tell you, knowledge of the precise time of day
is essential in the execution of our responsibilities.
This is why I am always assured that one of my assistants
is in the possession of an accurate chronometer.
Pardon me, William,
Yeah,
May I ask you to consult your chronometer
and to reveal to me its present readings.
Uh, yeah, sure, Brick
T T,
I'm not
Exactly. what are you saying?
I just don't quite understand.
Um, what time is it?
Oh, alright, yeah, it's ten-fifteen.
Thank you, my stalwart assistant.
Yeah, no problem.
Hmm,
Hey, Mr Mason, how you doing,
Do you know what time it is?
Well, as any scout should know,
if one orients themselves to direct north,
as I am doing now,
then you use the palm of your hand
as a measurement against the azimuth of the solar object,
Then one can determine the precise time of day.
Really,
Really, I don't know about that.
That is correct.
Really,
I make it to be ten-fifteen am.
Wow, it's earlier than I thought it was.
Thanks, Mr M.
I don't know.
You know, just holding your hands up and stuff like that
and looking at the sun, I don't know
I wouldn't trust it.
Let's go ask Mr Gilead.
Yeah, he's easier,
Mr Gilead, yeah, what time is it?
It's ten-fifteen.
Wow,
No kidding.
Yeah, I guess the old man knows what he's talking about, doesn't he?
I'll tell you, I'll never question him again.
Join us again for another exciting episode in the career of
Rick Mason.
Scoutmasters.
Well, how about that?
Hey, this is Podcast Number 60..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, before I get going, just forgive me if I've been a little behind
on answering emails or responding to comments on the blog.
I'm working on a new home for the Scoutmaster blog and podcast online
and I'm very excited about being able to expand some of the resources
that we offer and put everything in an updated format,
and I will make sure to tell you a little bit more about that soon.
It's not quite ready for prime time yet,
but I'm really looking forward to getting the new website launched.
This is what came across the Translum this week on the blog
about our interview with Les Stroud and his book Will to Live.
Jason had this to say: he says
it's a great book and, like you said,
it takes a little getting used to the style,
but after you do. it's a great read with amazing stories.
Got to agree, Jason,
One of the better books I've read so far this year.
We did a post on the blog about power tools
and CO Scouter got in touch and said
thanks very much for addressing this topic.
It, along with fixed blade knives,
are two areas where scouting legend rather than BSA policy
often seem to guide folks' actions.
Scouts often participate in inherently dangerous activities
like rock climbing and shooting and swimming and diving and hiking
and camping and clement weather.
These are the very things that often draw boys to scouting.
Our responsibility as adult leaders is to provide access
to these activities in the safest manner we can,
not to avoid them to keep ourselves absolutely safe.
Well, I got to agree with you there. CO
Challenge and, you know, measured risk-
that's all part of the program
and I often get questions about the use of power tools
and scouts and everything like that.
Go to the blog at scoutmastertypepadcom
and look at the post. Can Scouts Use Power Tools?
You'll get some answers for it.
Last time on Podcast 59, we talked about a few things.
Mark in San Diego wrote in to say this:
another classic podcast.
although some moms may not want their sons to grow up.
it is precisely these boys that benefit the most
from being away from home for a week without mom.
I think it's also exactly the case that the issue here is
not if the boy will survive, but if mom will survive.
Some moms kind of don't know what to do with themselves
except worry.
Yes, absolutely.
The best path is to have a wing woman-
Okay, Jason, I think I get that-
Instead of a wing man, a wing woman
who is going to step in and commiserate
As men. often there's just no way we can understand.
Just ask a mom and she will tell you.
there's no way we can understand,
Unbeknownst to me. last year my wing woman
set up a mom's night at her house
on the Wednesday of summer camp
for some of the moms to get together,
have some wine and get over the hump.
What a brilliant idea.
Hey, Jason, that is a good idea.
I'll have to float that one and see if it makes sense to anybody.
On homesickness, we had one case
where a first-year scout was getting
multiple letters a day from home
almost from the time we arrived at camp,
giving him more homesick rather than less.
For the first couple of days it was fine,
but it just got worse
After a while we just held on to those letters
and we gave them back to him before going home.
He was always too busy and having fun to be homesick
or take the time to read letters.
Last year we had a first-year scout
get seriously homesick, you know,
kind of crying and balled up on his cot in his tent.
Three older scouts would walk him all around camp
and just talk to him about stuff
and I can't describe how proud I am
of the compassion and sense of duty
the older scout showed in making sure he got through it.
This is one of my all-time favorite
assistant scout master moments.
The homesick boy is hooked for life.
He's not missed one troop meeting
or a camping trip all year.
Well, thanks, Jason for the comment,
and you know I got to agree.
when our older scouts reach out
they're compassionate, kind. you know human beings.
it's a huge difference, doesn't it?
And if you haven't caught on yet
and you didn't listen to the last podcast,
we were talking a little bit about the reluctant,
overcoming the reluctance of moms
to send first-year scouts to summer camp.
So go back and listen to podcast 59
if you haven't heard that, and you'll pick up on it.
Larry Geiger weighed in on the same podcast, same subject.
He says this:
I didn't develop a lot of sensitivity
to soothing mom's quivering worries,
but I've always had an assistant scout master
who's a lot more sensitive than I am.
The younger scouts always go to him.
Older scouts always come to me
about leadership problems and outdoor stuff.
You might be much more sensitive than I am.
I have letters of documentation
about how insensitive, inflexible,
indifferent and intransigent and rigid I am.
Oh well,
Larry, I think you're selling yourself short.
Yeah, you might feel that way,
but I don't think you're that way.
That was a great idea.
I sort of used my assistant scout master for that,
but I like the whole idea of moms talking to moms.
There's a whole range of ideas you could use
to make this work.
Keep the good stuff coming.
Well, we'll do our best, Larry,
and you keep on commenting.
We certainly do appreciate it.
Blaise Vitali, he wrote in.
he was featured in a call-in segment last week.
He says thanks for using my question
on this week's podcast.
I enjoyed the answer.
The new troop plans are coming together.
I'm also about halfway through
reading Working the Patrol Method, the book,
and I'm trying to have all the boys do a bit more.
However, at this level.
they seem to just want the adults to run the show.
Hopefully that will change as they get more experiences
camping next to other Boy Scout troops.
Yeah, they're going to catch on pretty quick, Blaise.
I wouldn't be too concerned about that
And I would suggest
reading Working the Patrol Method
to every new and old Scoutmaster out there.
It's a very worthy read.
Rob Ferris and Harry Wimbrow
and the guys did a fantastic job on that book.
And go to scoutmastertypedcom,
You'll see it right there.
Blaise went on to say
I wish there were a way
that you could teach meal planning
and preparation on the blog.
Yeah, well, we got a few things on there.
It seems the best way to learn this topic is by doing it,
but I don't want the troop to suffer
through the learning process.
Well, first of all, Blaise,
thanks for getting back in touch.
Always appreciate it.
I got to tell you cooking in Scouts,
something we've talked about many times.
yeah, I have like my expectation.
I hope that they bring food
and I hope that they cook it.
How about that?
You know ramen noodles.
they can be eaten in a brick without any water.
I know I've had Scouts prove it.
Yeah, how about that?
Also heard from Tom Gillard
from down in Tennessee.
He had some very nice things to say
and he also offered the story
That was the basis for our little brick mason segment
just before we got to you here.
So thanks very much, Tom,
And thanks for staying in touch.
I told you about this last week
and you still have a chance to do it.
If you're in the Wisconsin area,
there is an expedition canoeing school
by Cliff Jacobson.
It's going to be a weekend here
the first weekend in April
and there will be information about that.
If you're in the Wisconsin area
and you can get to that,
you're planning a canoe trip,
or if you're not planning a canoe trip,
spending a weekend with Cliff Jacobson,
who is a world-renowned canoe guide
and author, is well worth the time.
I wish I could get there,
but just can't make it to Wisconsin.
So look on the blog scoutmastertypepadcom
for a link to information
about the expedition canoeing school.
The Scoutmaster newsletter will be out this week
and the subject of the newsletter,
which is a review of the podcast and the blog
usually set up around a monthly theme,
is going to be bridge-crossing season,
And we're going to talk a little bit about that
in Scout Mastership in seven minutes
or less here in a moment.
But yeah, it's bridge-crossing season
and time to think about what goes on there
and how we can make that process work well
as we bring new Weeblows from their Weeblows Den
into the Boy Scout troops
And we got a great giveaway.
We have some products from E-Lite
and E-Lite is a really kind of a cool new
electrolyte replacement product
And for a few drops from a concentrate
added to any bottle of water
is going to give you a great electrolyte replacement.
And if you listened back when we were talking
with Dr Auerbach in the interview-
I think it was podcast 58 or 57,
Dr Auerbach recommended this product
and I went and found out about it,
And E-Lite people were good enough to give us some samples
and to give us a kit that we are going to make
the newsletter giveaway this time.
So make sure you're subscribed to the newsletter.
It comes by email once a month
And to subscribe you can go to scoutmastertypepadcom
and there you go, You'll be all set.
Well, we're going to talk a little bit about
welcoming Weeblows into the troop
and Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
All right, we got a couple other things to do
and that's plenty for this podcast.
So let's get started, shall we
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less?
Well, it's that time of year,
It's time to welcome new Scouts
who are crossing the bridge from their Weeblows, Dad.
And while I'm not going to go into
step-by-step logistics here,
I think it's important for us to take a moment
and discuss some of the broad underlying concepts
that are going to help make these new Scouts
into old Scouts one day.
Conventional wisdom says that that first year
of a Scout's experience in his new troop
is very, very important
And it has a large bearing on his continuing in Scouting
for the next several years.
Now there's a lot of shifting alliances
and interests in adolescence
that are beyond the control of any Scout Master.
But there are some important steps
that we can take to assure that
we're going to get these new guys
and they are going to stick with the program
and they're going to get something out of it.
Perhaps the first one is to kind of analyze
the relationships that are going on.
There's two or three different things to look at.
One is a relationship between your older Scouts
and your younger Scouts.
The other one is a relationship
between the newer Scouts
who are coming into the troop
that they have with each other,
And one is between your new family's parents
and yourself and the other adults
who are involved with the troop.
I wouldn't assume, because we below has joined a troop
as a den, that they should all remain together as a group.
Now. they may have been great high functioning,
They may have given great chemistry
amongst those boys and they may be good pals.
And you know, after the past couple of years
of being in a we below's den together,
maybe a couple of them have worn out
their welcome with each other.
So talking to a den leader
or the den chief who you've had in with,
that we below's den is a good idea.
Which of these boys work well together,
which of them are kind of bad juju,
if you know what I mean.
Which of them kind of set each other off?
That might be a big thing for their first year.
in making a few adjustments.
Many troops use the new scout patrol plan
very successfully.
I've adapted some of the concepts
and made a couple of changes
to adapt it to work in our troop.
A lot of times a we below's den will form a new patrol
and sometimes they'll become members of an existing patrol.
It really depends on the boys who are coming in
and the way that our patrols are set up at the time.
What I think is important is the scouts
aren't in some kind of junior patrol
or in a situation where they're
just totally overseen by adults
or have a lot of adult involvement in their patrol,
because that's basically just like
doing a third year of we below's.
Now I think they need to be a good, strong,
independent patrol, off on their own
doing their stuff.
It will take them a little while to catch on to that,
but a little mentoring and a little oversight
is a good thing, but giving them a lot of room
and making sure that they are in a real patrol.
Let's talk about the relationship
between your new scouts and your older scouts.
This can be a problem sometimes.
The attitude with which your troop
receives new scouts is crucial.
Now I don't have to really tell anybody
listening to this that we don't do hazing
or initiations or bullying in scouts.
We don't do that for adults,
We don't do that for youth.
Anyone who walks through the door
and signs a form is a full member
of scouting and your scout troop.
They're a full member of their patrol.
They are full participants
in every aspect of the program
and the program is planned to accommodate them
as well as the older scouts.
Now, it might take a little explaining,
It might take a little time,
but older scouts need to understand
that leadership is an opportunity for service,
not an excuse for exercising
their lordly authority over the little guys.
It's also important to them in their scouting
to advance in rank.
They're going to need to have
a position of responsibility,
and who are they going to be responsible for?
Well, these new guys.
Now, the new guys are going to tire them out.
The new guys aren't going to know what to do.
The new guys aren't going to be all that cool,
but we're going to work along with our older boys
to make sure that they understand
the importance of new scouts in their troop,
to remind them to be a little empathetic,
to remember what their experience was
when they came into the troop and how they felt
and the way that they looked up to
or respected the older scouts
or maybe had a problem with them.
But a little discussion about this is always in order
and it's always a good thing to sit down
with your youth leadership
and remind them how important all of this is
and how important it is to be friendly and kind
to the new scouts who are coming into the troop.
We want to have lots of positives.
We want to have acceptance and support
and positive reinforcement for our new guys.
We need to take every opportunity
to make them feel at home and safe and wanted.
We need to be careful not to belittle them.
We need to be careful not to, you know,
make a big thing out of their inevitable mistakes
or misconceptions about the way things go,
but just to help them along,
mentor and be kind and friendly to them.
The third relationship is the relationship
of the parents of new families
with the troop committee
and the scout master and things like that.
I have a new motto for this, called assume nothing.
Assume nothing.
I mean, if you've been around scouting for a while
and you and your family are used to it
and you know how to make things happen
and what happens at campouts and things like that,
we often will take that
and we'll kind of forget what it was like to be new
and to not know exactly what was going on with your son
or maybe where he was going
or what was going to happen at campouts and things,
And you know, truth be told,
I get a little tired of that.
I get a little tired of answering the same questions
over and over again,
but I do make sure that new parents
have all of my contact information
and understand that they can call me
with any question or concern that they have anytime
and we'll do our best to take care of it.
The other thing is our troop committee
puts together a little new parents orientation
and gets them together so that they can meet each other,
meet some of the other parents in the troop
and learn a little bit about the things
that are going to happen next
and how planning is done
and how preparations are made for campouts
and things like that.
You know, it's a vitally important thing
that I think a lot of troops end up missing sometimes
And when parents get discouraged,
scouts get discouraged,
And when scouts get discouraged
they vote with their feet
and they walk away from the scouting
and they walk away from the program.
So that's just a few thoughts
on how to make new scouts welcome
and how to make sure that they stay on
and become our older scouts
Music.
Hi, I'm Kevin Callum, the Happy Camper
and you're listening to the Scout Master Podcast
Music.
That's right, it's time for a scout master's minute
Well, you might not know this,
but I have spent most of my adult life as a carpenter.
That's right. I've been in the trades most of my adult life
and I can tell you from experience
that one of the most essential tools
for a carpenter to have is an accurate measuring tape.
It's a pretty important thing.
The other thing is, I can tell you,
is that the most overrated tool
that a carpenter has is a measuring tape.
And here's why
Sometimes, if you have to cut out a piece of wood
to fit into a space,
if you go and you measure
and you transfer the measurements
well, you can make a mistake
or you can misread something
A lot of times. it's easier
if it's possible to hold the piece of wood
right to the place where you need it
and mark it right. there
Don't need a measuring tape at all.
Now, what in the world does this have to do with scouts?
Well, boys are like boards.
I mean they're rarely uniform, featureless raw material.
They have twists and knots
and difficult cross-grained areas
that has to be adapted to the task at hand.
As scout masters, we might have measuring tapes
of rules and policies and requirements
from advancement to work on the boys with
and to measure their performance with,
but it's rarely that accurate.
It's rarely the way that it looks
in the books and the pictures right.
What it is is. it's making do with what we have
and making sure that the measurements we use
are individual.
Now your house is probably a good, secure,
dry, warm, durable place to live
and probably enjoyed a great deal.
Scouts likewise. they need to be decent people,
good citizens, capable leaders, reliable,
just like a good house.
Any carpenter who insisted that every dimension
of a house be consistent to the fraction of an inch
would end up being really frustrated,
because the world just doesn't work that way.
Any scout master who wants to make similar demands
on the precision of his scouts,
that they all measure up to the exact same thing,
that they all look alike, that they all act alike-
is going to find that they are trading
the perfectly acceptable for the absolutely perfect.
A dimensionally perfect house in theory is possible,
but it wouldn't function any better
than a house that maybe was off a quarter of an inch
here and there.
And get out of measuring tape and measure your own house
if you doubt it.
There isn't one out there.
There isn't a perfectly square, perfectly level,
perfectly plumb house in existence.
It just doesn't happen.
But they're very comfortable and they're secure
and they're durable and we enjoy living in them,
just the way that we want our scouts to be.
We want them to be comfortable and secure
and durable in life
And we do that not by measuring them
to the fraction of an inch,
but by making sure that the skills
that we share with them and the maturity they reach
fits the purpose at hand.
Remember, each one's a little different.
Each one measures up to the extent
of their highest reach
and his fellow scout's highest reach,
And the test of our work as Scoutmasters
is not perfect achievement,
but the character of our scout.
Well, thanks for listening once again
to the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch.
You can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastertypepadcom.
You can also subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes and, when you do,
feel free to leave a comment or a review
or a rating.
And you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter.
That's a monthly digest of the Scoutmaster blog
and podcast with some great scouting resources
around the monthly theme.
And remember, every newsletter includes
a great giveaway from one of our affiliate sponsors.
You can also follow us
at ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook
and ScoutmasterCG on Twitter.
You can email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
at ClarkGreen at gmailcom.
That's C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N
at gmailcom.
So here's what I'd like you to do.
I'd like you to be part of the Scoutmaster podcast.
That's right. I would like to hear your voice.
I would like you to be
included in podcast number 61
coming up next week.
It's an easy thing to do. All you have to do
is pick up the phone
and call
484-734-0002
and you'll leave
a voicemail comment
or a question or a funny story
and you just might be featured
in the Scoutmaster podcast next week.
That's right, You,
That's 484-734-0002,
and you'll leave a voicemail comment
or question or a funny story
and you just might be featured
in the Scoutmaster podcast next week.
That's right, You,
That's 484-734-0002..
I need to remind you the Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
Nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
No, it's just me talking into a microphone,
That's right, trying to lend a hand to Scout leaders
And hopefully have a little bit of fun along the way.
Well, before we leave you, let's hear from the founder of Scouting, Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Hey, Sir Robert, what have you got to tell us today?
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why thank you, Sir Robert?
Until next time.
Thank you, Sir Robert.